so I will start with what I hope will be
the most boring part of this
presentation I will introduce myself so
my name is Vlad econ enough I came here
from Israel I work in our industry for
almost 20 years nine of them in the role
of Software Architect and software
architecture is not only my job but it
also became a hobby I really loved you
know researching this topic blogging
about it and of course speaking at
conferences like this today I want to
talk about messenger messaging and more
specifically about the architectural
pattern we usually call events and the
thing is events there like everywhere
nowadays event-driven architecture is
based on events events events sourcing
finally getting the attention it
deserves it's also based on events
microservices are everywhere and many
are calling for integrating them
asynchronously through events as well
however this popularity came with a cost
some how many see the events as some
kind of you know secret sauce for
preparing distributed systems as if you
can take a monolith pour some events
over it boom you've got yourself micro
services the management design and of
course modern architecture of course
it's not really true events are not some
magic but they're just a tool and as any
tool it can be used to create some great
stuff but if you are going to abuse it
or misuse it it's a great way to take
your legs off and actually I have
experience of doing both so in the next
hour I want to share with you my
experience the mistakes I did how we
were able to fix them and most
importantly what we've learned from this
experience and I hope it will be helpful
to you and you will be able to
skip this learning phase and since we
are talking about an architectural
pattern I want to start from the basics
to make sure that we are on the same
page about what is software architecture
what are its goals and how to evaluate
software architecture like what's the
difference between a good one and a bad
one then we'll do the same for the event
pattern again we'll see the definition
of this pattern what an event is and
then we also see that not all events are
made the same
and instead actually there are three
types or flavors of events which are
used for messaging next I will share
some scary war stories on how
distributed system design can go wrong
and of course the discussion will be
based heavily on the preceding
theoretical part on software
architecture and events and I will
finish with three heuristics like simple
rules of thumb that I am using today
when applying messaging you know to
evaluate and keep distributed system
architecture contract on track so
without further ado what is software
architecture and when answering this
question usually two quotes come to mind
the first one is by Ralph Johnson who
said that architecture is about the
importance stuff whatever that is and
Martin Fowler who said that software
architecture is those decisions which
are both important and hard to change
now both these authors stressed the
importance of architecture and I guess
no one would argue with that right
we built software not for expressing
ourselves but to solve business problems
for organizations which are going to be
using this software and software can
make companies more efficient it can
increase their competitive advantage
profitability
in some cases software even enables the
business itself for example when
software is the company is the product
that company is selling there are four
robust software architecture and design
is not something which is nice to have
instead it's crucial for the success not
only of the system but of the whole
organization that is going to be serving
and that's what makes those
architectural decisions so important and
unfortunately hard for example eight
years ago I was the first employee of a
company called intra novice and I had to
plan and design its architecture from
scratch so we had to decide whether to
use self-manage servers or go to the
cloud they also like the old days before
cloud was cool
we also have had to choose whether to
dive into the brave new world of no
sequel or to stay where we are most
comfortable with relational databases of
course we also had to choose languages
frameworks patents architectural styles
etc now not only these decisions were
hard but they also involved lots of risk
you know one wrong step could make the
system way more complex to implement in
to maintain both in short and long terms
therefore in my opinion the goal of
software architecture is to manage
systems complexity and we manage this
architectural complexity by decomposing
systems in two sets of interconnected
components modules those modules can
appear at different levels they can be
methods classes namespaces services and
even whole systems but in this
presentation I will speak about modules
in context of a microservices so at
whatever
levels modules are they make it more
they make it easier to reason about
responsibility of each module and its
interactions with the
rest of the system moreover modularity
simplifies understanding of the system
as a whole with proper map a modules
it's easier to grasp what the system is
supposed to do and how does it work on
the architecture level modularity
reduces risk of the system's design it
limits the scope of those implementation
decisions to the scope of each module so
for one module you can choose for
example a relational database for
another one something more modern
in other words modularity helps us to
manage systems complexity it does that
by dividing this complexity into two
parts the first one is local complexity
local complexity is complexity of a
specific component and I think the
easiest way to demonstrate this idea is
you know if you have a module and you
want to evaluate it slow its local
complexity complexity ask how hard will
it be for a junior team member to grasp
what's going on inside of this module
water its goals what's the business
domain of it what it's doing and how
does it work for example in our company
we had a module which was in charge of
Commission's calculating Commission's
for sales agents and you know its public
API resembled a resembled a coherent set
of methods which all of them were
related in this way when I read those
Commission's on the other hand we had a
much bigger module and at some point in
code logic for managing advertising
campaigns contracts with publishers
creative catalog and even finances so
you know I don't need even a junior team
member sometimes I would look at it and
have no idea what's going on there
therefore its local local complexity
it's way way higher the second type of
systems complexity is
global complexity it is defined by the
level of interconnectedness between the
system's components with low
interconnectedness you know it's easier
to understand what role each component
plays in the system and it's also easier
to evolve components you know since
modifications will have lower impact too
on the rest of the system we are
modifying only one component here's an
example with relatively I think it's it
has a low global complexity it has five
components and you know we can trace all
the dependency between them and on the
other hand here we have the same number
of components but way more connections
between them and that makes global
complexity of this system higher than
the previous one
thus this process of defining components
boundaries is actually a key
architectural decision proper boundaries
reduce complexity of the system and make
it more adaptable to future requirements
and changes so if you go back to the
question of what is software
architecture I think Ruth Millan gave a
crystal clear answer
she said that system design is
inherently about boundaries what's in
what's out what spends and what moves
between those boundaries it reshapes
what's outside just as it shapes what is
inside so system design is about drawing
components boundaries and speaking of
what moves between those boundaries
let's talk about events as I said in the
introduction it's a common practice
today to use events for loosening
coupling between the systems systems
components right and the idea behind
this pattern is actually very simple an
event is just a message which is used as
a contract for integrating systems some
system can
publish its events and other systems who
are interested in that information can
subscribe to those events therefore in
this scenario the event plays the role
of integration contract between those
systems of course events can take
different forms they can be a JSON
documents XML files protobuf but
whatever way you choose to represent the
events the idea behind them is the same
an event is just a data structure with
no behavior attached to it it only
represent represents something
interesting that happened in the past
for example in our company we have event
called click impression campaign started
a paycheck generated etc now if you look
into what's going in what's going on
inside of the event usually it contains
its type some meta data for example a
timestamp a name of the system that
created it and of course the payload you
know the specific content of the event
message however payload is were those
events really differ and actually there
are three types of different events in
here's article called
what you mean by event-driven Martin
Fowler identifies three types of events
the first one is what he calls event
notification such event is used to
notify that something important has
happened and the key here is to notify
the source system doesn't expect any
direct or indirect maybe indirect but it
doesn't expect any direct response to
the event and in fact it isn't even
aware who the subscribers are for that
specific event also such event contains
minimal information on nature of the
change for example what was change
changed in the systems data because of
this event I subscribe
if it's interested in knowing that
information you know can execute the
query against the source system and to
get the more detailed information in
some sent event notifications you know
it's like pager everybody knows where
the pager is good so here is well you
get a event notification okay some stuff
is going on but you have to call the
number to get the more detailed
information about what's happened the
next type is what Martin Fowler calls
event carried State transfer and here
the original originating system not
notified that something has happened
but the message contains all the
information that was changed because of
some business transaction it can come in
two forms the first one let's say you
have some customer entity so the event
can contain a snapshot of this customer
state the updated state the second form
is to specify what were the fields that
actually changed because of the business
transaction so if for example you have
like 200 different fields and only two
of them change so we just publish what
changed and not all of them in any way
this information is supposed to be
sufficient for the subscribers and they
don't have to query the publisher for
additional details as in the case for
the event notification and of course the
obvious advantage of this approach is
the considerably lower dependency of
subscribers on the publishers it both
make the subscribers more resilient they
can continue function even if the
publisher is down for some reason they
have local snapshot of all the data and
it also lowers the risk on the publisher
themselves so if some subscriber is
going crazy and he really needs to
process some information many many times
it's not going to affect the publisher
because that subscriber has all data
locally and the final type is the events
used for event sourcing and usually
they're called domain events do I have
to give a small introduction about event
sourcing yes
okay so I'll do it briefly event
sourcing is a different way of
representing system state if for example
we in traditional systems we have some
database record which represents the
current state of some
entity of the system for example
customer ID I know something his name is
John last name John some status and when
you're looking at this record do you
know its current state event sourcing is
a different and kind of interesting way
to represent the same data it includes
the dimension of time so instead of
storing the current state you are
stirring the complete list of events
that led to the state so the customer
was initialized then he have there his
contact details and such etc and you can
always go through those events to
calculate the current state so that's a
venture in 101 so for event sourcing we
are using events as well those are
usually called domain events and as I
said each change the system state is
represented by an event and such events
are somewhere in between so somewhere in
between those previous two types as
notification events they do notify that
something important has happened but
they also have to contain data that
describes what actually has happened
this data however should be modeled as
close as possible to the business domain
it not some particular state or
presentation as in the case of events
for carrying a changes in state the
previous
that's why usually when speaking about
domain events people describe them as as
stateless stateless in a sense as Marian
Duncan Jones says here event should be
stateless as regards the entity to which
event occurred in other words money
deposited event holds no data on the
account balance if you know the balance
you can always run through those domain
events and calculate from scratch so
those are the three types of events I
will quickly summarize them with a small
example notification event again only
signals that something has happened
for example marriage or divorce event
correct a transfer is basically data
replication mechanism through events and
an example would be personal details
changed event such event may be fired
when a person's last name changes
however unlike notification event it
would have no connection to the reason
whether it's because a marriage or
divorce adjust the fact his last name
was changed and finally domain events
are somewhere in between they do reflect
the reason for example married and all
the related data but they again they
shouldn't be coupled to a specific state
representation they should reflect so
much as possible the business domain and
not some kind of a projection of it or
model it and it's crucial to choose the
correct event type for a specific task
otherwise instead of modern architecture
architecture you will end up with
accidental complexity and even the
dreaded distributed models to
demonstrate it I want to share some war
and horror stories from the company I've
been working at for the last eight years
as I said the companies in Chernobyl and
our goal was to allow companies that are
producing for example products or
services to outsource their marketing
related chores so they will come to us
and we'll create a advertising materials
will publish advertising campaigns will
optimize them to make sure you know that
spend Allah spend the least and they're
the most effective collect the leads
from those campaigns and eventually our
sales agents would make the calls to
sell our clients products pretty complex
and white business domain and as it
usually happens initially we try to
implement it as one huge monolith and
complexity wise you know the system who
had very low global complexity because
hey we have only one component but this
components local complexity was huge
everything was in it and unsurprisingly
after some time this design started
breaking under its own weight
it became slow hard to test and overall
unpredictable so at some point we
decided ok we cannot take it anymore we
have to break this monolith into two sub
systems marketing and serum that's what
it looked like marketing system it was
in charge of collecting and publishing
marketing events for example impression
click submitted late etc and this
marketing system was kind of stupid it
didn't really do anything with those
events
apart from publishing them to the
subscribers the subscribers were free to
pick up those events and do whatever
they need with their data so those
subscribers included first of all our
CRM system our bi department you know
they wanted to analyze what's going on
in
in our marketing domain and our clients
organizations that were using our
services they also need to get some
notification about marketing events so
those subscribers were free to make
their own decisions on how to project
those marketing events into some kind of
their own state which is going to be
convenient for their needs
architectural wise the goal was of the
of this redesign was to lower local
complexity of the systems components and
we did once we started decoupling and
those different concerns local
complexity went down no arguing about
that now let's see what happened to the
global complexity here
as time passed we'll notice that this
state this state calculation logic here
on the right side how does that work oh
it works the first time I'm ever using
it so this state calculations which is
performed by all of the subscribers was
duplicated across all of them you know
despite the freedom to choose whatever
model they need all of them projected
the same data as a result the business
logic that generated that state was
duplicated across all of them and that
introduced what I call logical coupling
between these components this business
logic was duplicated across three
different systems and it had to change
simultaneously also we were at some
point we were hit in the face by
unreliability of network here on the
left side on the publishing side we
naively assumed that whatever we are
going to publish from the marketing
system all those events will be
delivered in the same order
they are published and they will be
delivered exactly once as if this whole
system X is one big logical transaction
of course that's not possible
and well the moment things didn't go as
planned the same sets of events produced
different results for different
subscribers they had the same business
logic that process them but because of
the nature of network but some of the
events arrived out of order they a
calculated different results now to fix
this we had to employ some
infrastructure infrastructure who do you
know which entered entangled those
components even more and bottom line
whatever you look at it with this may
Buddha or without this woudl this system
has a very high global complexity all
its components are entangled and really
strongly coupled to each other the
solution was to refactor marketing into
an event search system and instead of
publishing notification events it
emitted some minimal workable state that
would be enough for the subscribers need
need from the Vance perspective we went
from I would say we went from event
notification to event period state
transfer so instead instead of PO has
thrown raw data on the clients this
server and this service took care of
this business logic that projected this
state and published this changes in the
state to all the consumers through event
carrier state transfer this refactoring
all over both the global complexity of
the whole system and the local
complexity of its components because
first of all those subscribers didn't
need this state calculation logic
anymore
it resided only in one place so that's
what our a final decomposition look like
marketing emitted an event correct state
change events which were received by
those subscribers and they created their
local copies of them and then do a did
their job
now speaking of this CRM system in the
middle originally we implemented it in a
traditional way it stores the data in a
relational database however after some
time this implementation was limiting us
in multiple ways first it was hard to
scale a relational database second it
limited us to the relational model but
bi people they needed a more a way to
get more insight into the into the data
so they continued continually bombarded
us with some weird requests add this
field here that field they're
calculating amount of times for example
a customer change his phone number and
stuff like that and of course we had
limited success implemented with this
rigid in a relational model and third we
wanted to break out of this a relational
database prison and instead to embrace
the polyglot persistent model to use
multiple days databases you know to get
the benefits of each type of databases
database for cash for operations for
reading such and such' so to achieve
these goals
we refactored this serum system into an
events or advanced sourcing and securest
based system do I need to give you a
quick introduction to secure us anyone
okay
so in CQRS is a pattern you know that
allows you to represent the same data in
multiple a persistent models and that's
what our initial implementation looked
like it was pretty much by the book so
the client would submit a command its
execution would result in new domain
events that were appended to the event
store and projected interview models
finally the comments result was
communicated from those read models back
to the users so those were the so-called
one-way commands but the thing is there
is no such thing as a one-way command
one-way command is an event a system
should be able to refuse execution of a
command and of course communicate back
to the user
the reason why it was refused was this
an infrastructural issue or maybe the
comment was invalid and if it's if it
was invalid then what are the validation
issues how can he fix those errors and
submit the proper command so our users
were also you know they were not really
happy about this secure thing because
they expected to get result results
immediately
for example if a sales agent executed a
command will change state of a customer
well he expected to see the result of
this operation displayed immediately on
the screen once he got is okay from the
server naturally he expected to see the
updated data on his screen and that's
understandable so at some point again we
decided that this system needs a change
so to fix this we implemented proper
commands now they were executed
synchronously and the execution result
was delivered immediately to the
as part of request/response model you
know a simple restful call now moreover
in some cases the execution result not
only returned the execution result of
the command did that succeed or fail if
it well if it failed why but also we
returned updated data as well which was
supposed to be displayed on the UI now
here here is the tricky part
that was like a shortcut because we
according to everyone who is doing say
qrs that's something that you are not
supposed to do however if you're
returning data that originates from a
strongly consistent data store the event
store then you can just return it there
is no point in waiting for for it to be
projected into those real models the
limitation is you cannot return
projected data why because again you're
turning the result as fast as possible
but projections are asynchronous and it
will take time propagate those changes
across all projections so physically you
are not able to do it
you can only only return data from a
strongly consistent store and again the
result of this was much better user
experience for our self agents now let's
talk more in depth about this projection
stick the serum system publish those
domain events which were used for event
sourcing as its public API and it
expected other system to leverage that
freedom of generating their own
projections so here we have 100
different event types do whatever you
want
good luck and of course
this honeymoon period and it very
quickly at some point we realized that
you know 90% of those subscribers we're
projecting the same model
despite the freedom to adapt they stick
with their own with the same model which
was used by almost all of them and again
as in the case of marketing system this
introduced logical coupling the logic
that projected events into a workable
state was duplicated in all those
subscribing components not only it was
duplicated but because it held in
knowledge of how each domain affects the
state it was coupled to the serums
implementation details and as a result
it caused another type of coupling
implementation coupling all those
subscribers had to close the follow
changes in serums implementation if when
you have a type of events what was added
was introduced they had to reflect this
in their code as fast as possible why
because even you have a new event can
affect the value of some of their fields
that they are projecting ignoring this
event eventually will lead to
inconsistent data something that usually
business people are not really happy
about and finally we have here a third
type of coupling and this one is more
subtle one I call it semantic coupling
some events in the CRM system were not
defined clearly and subscribers had to
make assumptions on meanings of those
events for example we have this event
here agent assigned to lead now the
question is what does it mean when a
subscriber receives three such events
does it mean that three agents are
assigned to the need or only the last
one
the event is schema doesn't you know
tell this a difference
doesn't communicate this knowledge so
the subscribers had to make assumptions
or the implementation details and
sometimes they did they they made
different assumptions so to sum it up if
we were to evaluate this architecture
again it screams scream that has high
global complexity despite messaging and
all those services all systems
components are again tightly coupled to
each other because of implementation
logical and semantic couplings now to
decouple this mess what we did is we
encapsulated the state projecting logic
in the CRM system itself so instead of
exposing its domain events it published
published changes to the projected state
through event carried state transfer
effectively the serums public API now
compressed its implementation details
those domain events into a more
restricted and limited set of public
events which were just used to notify
subscribers about changes in the state
of those editors of course it did raise
the local complexity of the CRM system
again we moved some logic that wasn't
there before
but again that's nothing really serious
because first of all it's really
coherent with what was there in the
first place it all works and operates on
the same data on the same schema and
usually both the original code and the
new one they are changing in the same
pace so this change didn't have any
considerable effect on a the local
complexity of the CRM system however
this refactoring dramatically reduced
global complexity of the whole system
because again we removed all those
sources for
couplings between those components
next story one day our managers decided
to try working with a new business
vertical you know to evaluate a new way
of making money and for that I needed a
new system so this system was defined in
the manager in design terms as core
business domain that's how our company
was going to make money so technically
we had to invest our most advanced tools
in design of this project so back in
those days this micro-services trend
started appearing we heard about about
those micro services superhero companies
doing great stuff with this pattern so
we decided to give it a try so we
decompose this business domains into
those tiny tiny services
well tiny because micro right it should
be small and we actually if there was
not only asynchronous communication
between them also also some of them
communicated seeing Krista but that
doesn't really matter over time however
all those micro services became more and
more chatty and more and more connection
started adding up between them until at
some point almost all of them needed
data from all other services to complete
some of its operations and as you can
see here global complexity of this
solution skyrocketed suddenly all those
systems components became entangled and
very tightly coupled to each other now
it was really hard to change this
decomposition and you know we were
really we were really optimistic we
thought that it will be to be better
soon it wasn't of course the solution
was first of all to realize that we
naively decomposed the system without
being familiar enough with with its
business domain so those boundaries were
wrong from the beginning
and what we had to do is to merge them
together yeah to lower the global
complexity of the system to raise the
local complexity of this component but
only then you know we could decompose it
into a more limited set of components
and with more coherent business behavior
in each of them
for the fifth story actually
I cannot trash talk too much because I
wasn't involved directly in this
implementation so I will try not to
restrain myself about a year ago we our
company was merged with another company
and that new company was building a
trading platform and here is what I
external de pond when we were doing
architectural reviews the system would
process commands from from its users
those commands resulted in a transaction
against a relational database and then
events which were published to a message
bus Kafka in this case and of course the
goal of this distribution here was to
create a distributed system a scalable
system and you know overall modern
architecture now the obvious problem
here is we have
transactional coupling here this
operation assumes assumes that it can be
executed in the same transaction which
it can't infrastructural wise you know
without going into distributed
transactions you know you want to keep
it sane so implementation wise it wasn't
possible to guarantee this transaction
against two stores relational database
and a message bus and what happened if
the server went down in the middle of
process processing one of the commands
if it already committed data
to the database and then it the server
failed before publishing the events
none of the subscribers were had any
clue about that operation those event
not only they were not delivered
they didn't even exist at all in any
place there was no trace of them now
also the order of the events here is
important as well but again it wasn't
enforced in any way by the producer
those events were just generated not
stored in the database
generated in memory and published and of
course we cannot use time step for
ordering the events the system run a
runs on multiple servers and each server
can have a different local time so that
introduced an additional dimension of
transactional coupling they say this
system assumed that all consumers will
process the events in the same order as
they were published by the producer now
let's see what those consumers are
actually doing with those events so the
first one is committing the events into
some kind of backup database nothing
really interesting could be boring the
next one however projected a state out
of those event events and stirred that
state in a cache database and the last
subscriber which was used to process
events for the analysis systems for the
BI what I did is when it received the
event first it would enrich the original
event from the state from this cache
right here now what happened is this
last line here actually introduced
temporal coupling in a distributed
system in a synchronously communicated
system those events can be processed by
the
analysis subscriber only after they were
processed by this state generating
subscriber and of course it's very
challenging to implement so no one
really did it as a result the events
that were submitted to BI were enriched
with the wrong State not always it
reflect reflected the most up-to-date
state from this cache in other words it
corrupted data and of course the
simplest solution here is the outbox
pattern you know to leverage the
relational database which is already
used by the system so when the system
modifies some state in those relational
tables to add an additional table called
outbox and write out all the events that
are about to be published as a result of
that operation into that event a sort
internet table and then then after this
transaction is committed some relay can
pick up those events from that table and
publish them to the message bus and this
way it decouples all those you know
logical and transactional couplings
between those components and the worst
horror story is about a nice
microservices based system it was really
nice it had low global complexity there
were those micro services were really
coherent there were not really coupled
with with each other and you know local
complexities of the services of
themselves
we were pretty low as well you know a
dream however one day we had to
introduce a new micro service and that
new micro service had to process data
from all of them it had to subscribe to
events from all those services do some
magic and then communicate this magic
back to them asynchronously so what
happened here is this new micro service
introduced a whole lot of implementation
coupling which spanned across all of
this system so what was a properly
decomposed system became an entangled
distributed monolith because one
properly designed service I call it
architectural Trojan horse the solution
we the solution that we picked was to
use domain driven design anti-corruption
pattern into corruption layer pattern
sorry to separate the integration
complexity from the business complexity
of the new server the new service so
this layer right here what I did is
actually collected data from the rest of
the system transform that into some
workable state which was more convenient
for this new micro service and in that
way the this new micro service which was
pretty complex it has very a complex
business logic
it was decouple from the rest of the
system the coupling was the coupling to
the rest of the system was here by this
anti-corruption layer but because there
was no you know complex business logic
here there was something tolerable
anyway it was much more convenient than
this previous scenario
so that's domain driven design and the
corruption layer so now I finished with
those scary stories and to summarize
them I want to share three rules of
thumb that actually sums up all the
problems that I've just shown you and
the solutions that we used eventually to
solve so first of all when designing
event-driven systems be
pessimistic about everything do not may
even assume that everything will work no
things will fail all the time
and usually on Saturdays this optimistic
consistency model as I've shown you here
it can be called a data corruption it
will corrupt the data and usually when
when you income encounter such a such
problem in the design people oh yeah but
you know how often will it happen if we
have 1% of those events being lost
who will notice and you know that's the
scary because the system is going
to corrupt the data and no one will
notice
so don't you lie on optimistic
consistency
make sure those events are all always
delivered to the subscribers you know
the word driven is is there in
event-driven architecture for reason
make sure those events are delivered to
the subscribers no matter what now some
events can can really be implementation
details especially those domain events
as in events or systems and it's usually
tempting you know to expose them as
public API but you do not want external
systems to depend on your implementation
details you need to be able to change
the implementation details as you are
working on your requirements your
clients on the other hand expect to get
a more stable API which is not going to
change often
so therefore use some events as private
implementation details and other events
as public API and again private can be
very default a detailed domain events
like many of them many different types
of events and you can change to change
them as you like but for the public API
press those private events into a more
restricted in a more stable of public
events and of course use the correct
type of events for your need in this
case event carrier state transfer is the
better option for integrating services
now if you're going to neglect this and
choose wrong event visibility it will
introduce logical coupling between the
systems components it will lead to
overtime it will for sure lead to
duplicated logic between your systems
components now instead of going async by
default when integrating services
evaluate their consistency requirements
so if you're integrating to
microservices what happen here to
patiently about it if you have two micro
services and when integrating them
eventual eventual consistency is
acceptable that's great use asynchronous
communication through events and of
course a event carry state transfer is
the natural choice for such a
communication between for integrating
them if on the other hand you have two
micro services and one of them always
expects to read the rest written
information by the second one it expects
to read the last right then you have a
bit more challenging situation in this
case you cannot just use those event
carriers state transfer events and you
know deliver them asynchronously in this
case the simple thing will be just to
issue a synchronous call you know a get
request give me this data and you will
always receive the most up-to-date
information another option would be for
the source to publish an event
notification saying hey something
interesting has
happened but if you're interested in the
data call me synchronously and I will
give it to you and finally if you have
two microservices and there are some
operations which cannot be executed
concurrently like one operation one
service another one in the second you
cannot execute them concurrently only
one can be executed at the same time
here stop whatever you're doing and
merge them those services together
because that's the shortcut to enormous
global complexity of the system and to
wrap this whole thing up I will go very
briefly about everything I've shown you
so software architectures goal is to
manage complexity it divides software
architecture divide systems complexities
into two types local complexity
complexity on the component level and
global complexity is level of
interconnectedness between the systems
components there are three types of
events notification event which says
that hey something interesting has
happened event carrier State transfer
for publish and changes in data between
services and domain events which not
find that something interesting has
happened in the business domain again
there are somewhere in between those two
previous types these are heuristics
first of all be pessimistic assume that
things are going to fail and make sure
that your system is delivering the
events no matter what use private and
public events to limit the public API of
components and evaluate consistency
requirements to choose the correct way
of integrating services and I think I'm
done here and we have five more minutes
for questions if there are any
yeah so look that's a great question and
before diving into an implementation of
those events or systems we always
evaluated the expected lifetime of those
business entities and for example in our
CRM system you know we would like our
customer to be a long-lived
to have transactions which will spend
years but usually the their lifespan is
limited by let's say 100 200 events so
so we just maintain the state it's just
cheaper to keep it instead of you know
doing those generating snapshots or
archiving it and in another system in in
those come in the Commission's module
you know we have this detailed monetary
transactions and they're actually you
know we to pay less for storage storage
we had to retire some of the data
archive it if for example a sales agent
is no longer working for us no point in
holding it there we just move it to a
file from the database in a flat file
and that's it does that answer your
question
you mean
oh that's a great question well so when
you are publishing those events usually
you can publish it okay so the question
was if let's say you have an event
events or system which is a not only
event so any system which publishes the
events how the subscribers can fetch the
events that were lost because of some
infrastructural issue for example
servers run down how does it know that
okay something has missed so the first
and easiest option you know Eastern
should use aq each subscriber has local
q which belongs to the subscriber so
when it goes down goes back up it just
reached the q again that's the easy part
however that's asynchronous publishing
of the events through this queue however
we encountered some situations where for
example subscribers had bugs in their
business logic so they couldn't rely on
this queue they will have to ask the
publisher to republish all the events
and publisher say no I'm not doing it so
in such a case we always prefer the
event source in the publishers to expose
to api's for the event first one is
asynchronous through queue and second is
what's called ketchup subscription we're
just going by some timestamp so you
always keep the last a record idea of
the record you can always get know the
delta what happen after it you can
reverse it the other way that answer
your question any more questions one two
three sold no more questions if I still
still didn't worry to death enough you
can follow me on Twitter I blog about
the stuff recently I was honored to
participate in this book project who I
wrote the story of our company but more
from the domain driven design
perspective and this book is really free
so there is no reason I forget it that
was my little shameless plug thanks so
much
[Applause]